et le gouvernement français ait un qui
mise sur la campagne de vaccination mais
peine à convaincre certains parents
réticents on a parlé une vaccination qui
a du coup dû mal à décoller dans le
cadre scolaire la tranche d'âge des
12-17 ans affiche un taux de 70% de
primo vacciner 58% reçu alors de doses
pour l'ensemble des français on a
franchi la semaine dernière la barre des
50 millions de primo vacciner s'il
s'agit d'une étape importante pour
l'exécutif certains territoires accusent
d'importants retards comme le
département de seine saint denis
l'éclairage de david khalifa
fierté affichée par l'exécutif mais
réalité beaucoup moins flatteuse une
réalité représentatif d'une fracture
sociale qui continue de se creuser avec
le kobe 19 ce cap des 50 millions de
primes ont vacciné révèlent des
disparités entre des territoires sur
vacciner et d'autres sous vacciner
certaines villes du 93 en fait partie
malgré le 26e drôme du stade de france
où je me trouve actuelle emmanuel
vigneron géographe à réaliser cette
carte en se basant sur les données de
l'assurance maladie depuis le 25 juillet
une carte qui donne un indice de
vaccination des intercommunalités
jusqu'au 5 septembre dernier on
s'aperçoit que le clivage est bien réel
entre le sud est de la france et le nord
une situation qui n'a pas évolué depuis
l'annnonce du pass sanitaire dans ces
territoires quand on regarde de plus
près la région ile de france le constat
est le même pour la seine saint denis
les quartiers défavorisés accuse les
retards les plus importants dans ces
zones situées à quelques kilomètres de
la capitale près de 50% de la population
n'a pas reçu la moindre dose de vaccin
globalement les premiers sont toujours
les premiers et les derniers toujours
les derniers c'est le signe d'une
dimension territoriale forte de la
résistance à la vaccination
cela peut être aussi celui de trous dans
la raquette du dispositif vaccinale les
deux pouvant se cumuler si le professeur
évoque un trou dans la raquette c'est
que l'intégralité des populations nous
encore vaccinés ne peut être mise sur le
compte d'un rejet des vaccins pour
rappel le ministère de la santé estime
que 8 millions cinq cent mille personnes
restent à convaincre en france
s'agissant de la vaccination mais pour
la plupart des gens qui habitent elle
dans ces quartiers défavorisés ne s'agit
pas d'une résistance ou d'un refus mais
tout d'un manque d'accompagnement jugez
plutôt par vous-même parmi les 50
territoires les moins vacciner du pays
10% sont situés en seine saint denis
clichy sous bois villetaneuse teint ou
bien encore villepinte les raisons de ce
décalage sont nombreuses et parfois
assez surprenante selon les
infrastructures en charge de combler ce
retard au sein des populations éloignées
elle des soins les réticences sont bien
souvent liée à la barrière de la langue
ou à la crainte d'une expulsion pour
ceux dont les papiers ne sont pas en
règle certains pensant même que le
vaccin est payant dans les quartiers
nord de marseille à la maison de santé
des aygalades où l'on vaccine le week
end l'une des premières choses qu'on
précise bien quand on appelle les
habitants c'est que le vaccin est
gratuit
ça peut paraître aberrant mais certains
pensent encore que c'est payant face à
cette crise sanitaire il faut vraiment
adapté une vaccination au plus près des
gens
parce que c'est aussi une question de
confiance c'est aussi des réseaux qui
savent se mettre en mouvement rien ne
remplacera la vaccination au plus près
des gens donc c'est à dire des centres
des vaccins proximité je ne dis pas des
centres de vaccins
communal mais vraiment très proche des
gens y compris loin ce temps on peut on
peut aisément aussi vacciner des
personnes qui sont sur les quartiers
nord de saint denis donc tout proche de
stones etc vous l'aurez compris le
retard de la vaccination dans certains
endroits du pays est un problème bien
plus profond pour la france celui des
inégalités sanitaires en fonction des
territoires une prise de conscience qui
servira peut-être d'électrochoc à
l'exécutif pour considérer un mal et qui
était présent bien avant la crise
sanitaire